i don't want to be called an actor i  don't want to be called a star i don't  want to have a label  i want to  have a legacy  i want  to be  known as someone  who has goals and achieves them and  whatever they might be wherever they  might be i want to be limitless i want  to break stereotypes i want to go where  no man or woman has gone before and it  might be a scary path and it might be a  path that no one's taken but at least  it'll be just mine  i had the worst self-esteem when i was a  kid i was  made fun of because the way i talked  because of where i came from i was made  fun of on every level and the only way  you can change that is  setting goals for yourself and saying i  will be the best version of me